mesdames messieurs bonsoir cette fois
c'est fait le psg champion de france de
foot 85 86
une victoire que l'on attendait depuis
50 ans et fait unique dans les annales
de ce sport les parisiens sont restés
invaincus pendant vingt-six matches
autant vous dire que l'ambiance était
chaude à hier soir au parc des princes
après le match la fête s'est
immédiatement transporté les tribunes
sur le stade le psg a eu droit à un
triomphe légitime champagne de rigueur
généreusement répandues par fernandez le
capitaine de l'équipe vous l'avez vu
maillot du psg jeté en pâture le tout
s'achevant par un tour d'honneur sur la
pelouse du parc
et puis point d'orgue de ce jour de
gloire si j'ose dire
un feu d'artifice bref la fête au
complet